from the moment I took my first steps
onto the frigid mountain tops outside
the city of kyovichard in Diablo 4. it
was clear that blizzard was serious
about responding to some of the
complaints of Diablo 3 while Diablo 3
contrasted pops of bright colors against
its grotesque horrors of the world
Diablo 4 is immediately more oppressive
and dire in its presentation its Hues
are muted and gray its World uninviting
and harsh its stories seemingly primed
to expose the worst parts of its
characters and yet it doesn't seek to
leave everything of its former entry
behind
in many ways this early slice of Diablo
4 offered a good sense of how most of
the mechanical changes introduced in
Diablo 3 and more recently Diablo
Immortal have been smartly iterated on
to maintain exciting action with the
satisfaction of flexible character
construction atmosphere is just one
facet where Diablo 4 is immediately
distinct from the series previous entry
Diablo 3's approach to class builds was
divisive with the far more streamlined
approach to Ability choices stifling
creativity in some cases Diablo 4
rectifies this in some smart ways while
still retaining approachability the
skill tree is made up of distinct nodes
with each one splintering outwards with
numerous abilities and Associated
upgrades investing points anywhere in
the skill tree Works towards unlocking
the next node and more abilities giving
you flexibility in how you reach each
one being able to easily respect is core
to the freedom them that Diablo 4 is
designed to give players at any point
you can choose to use gold to refund
points spent on a specific ability or
redo your skill tree entirely there's no
special Merchant you need to visit or
scarce resources you need to gather
while the cost is still being iterated
on game director Joe Shelley explained
in an interview that this decision was
made to encourage players to personalize
their builds throughout their time with
the game player choice is extended to
overall progression through Diablo 4's
Story 2 with blizzard adopting a
non-linear approach to how events unfold
once I had reached the first main town
of kyovashod and linked up with some key
characters I was given the choice of
three main story missions to pursue two
of them which weren't available in this
build of the game were situated quite
far away in entirely new regions that
required a slightly higher level
character than I was currently at the
other was conveniently close by but this
approach demonstrated that Lilith's
influence and the order in which you
experience its spread doesn't have to be
the same as another players while you
are pushed to play them in a specific
order according to the Character level
that each one suggests there's nothing
stopping you from not engaging with the
most readily available one leveling up
through other content and continuing
down a different path it's an approach
that acknowledges that many Diablo
players don't always perceive the game's
story with the same importance as others
and it's a fact that blizzard is
acknowledging so much so that once you
complete the story at least once with a
single character subsequent runs with
any of your characters won't require you
to engage with the story at all instead
you can opt out of it entirely once you
start a new campaign immediately opening
towns to other players you'll encounter
dynamically online and freeing up
dungeons for you to explore that might
have otherwise been tied up in story
specific encounters to supplement this
playstyle Diablo 4 offers a wealth of
additional content you can engage with
to level up and acquire critical loot
these are broken down into numerous
categories Each of which describe the
level of challenge they provide and the
potential rewards they offer sellers for
example are short combat encounters that
could have been minibosses in larger
dungeons offering small but sometimes
important pieces of random loot as
rewards dungeons which were plentiful
around just the small areas of the
fractured Peaks that I was allowed to
roam in are much more involved their
familiar mazes with multiple levels all
of which you can now explore seamlessly
without loading from one portion to the
next
Diablo 4's open world structure supports
the Litany of side quests and events
that it has to offer with a much
stronger sense of exploration in just
the first portion of the map I was
allowed to move through each of the
game's five larger regions is segmented
into multiple smaller ones each with
their own twisting roots that funnel you
in one cardinal direction or another
moving through these spaces provides
some nice visual distinction between
each area from wet and rainy bogs to
snow-covered Peaks and gloomy Barren
forests they also let you poke and prod
at Each corner uncovering pockets of
tough enemies to challenge new dungeons
to explore sellers to pillage and a
variety of public events that you can
share with other players you also earn
Renown and alternative resource to
experience simply by interacting with
the world whether it's finding new towns
and waypoints completing public events
or engaging inside quests and more
renowned unlocks rewards once you've
accrued enough with instant gold and
experience bounties but also more
permanent upgrades such as the number of
healing vials you can carry these
unlocks persist between characters
meaning you won't have to uncover the
entire map again or engage with loads of
world events with a new character when
you're just trying to quickly get to the
end game which seems like a good
decision the density and intricacy of
Diablo 4's World feels drastically
different from the linear design of
Diablo 3s which despite having some open
areas always felt like it was pushing
you in one direction towards the next
big story beat never mind the DraStic
Cuts between regions when shifting from
one act to another the entire map of
Diablo 4 is described as larger than
most previous Maps combined and just
this small taste of the fractured Peaks
strongly suggested that to be true
Diablo 4's Dynamic open world events
which act like public events that you
find in a game like Destiny 2 are shared
with other players that seamlessly pop
in and out of your server unlike Diablo
Immortal for example you won't choose a
specific server to play on rather Diablo
4's regions are all their own separate
instances with varying numbers of
players in each meaning you'll
gracefully transition from one densely
populated area to a more sparsely
populated one without realizing it the
populated regions and presence of other
players feeds into open world activities
that require more cooperation
strongholds are challenging combat
instances with distinct objectives that
take place in camps with enemies a step
or two above your current level are the
events such as End Game World bosses
which weren't in this build indicated
that blizzard sees value in weaving
these larger social experiences into the
most important facets of Diablo's core
Loop and that their activities you'll
likely need to engage in if you're
interested in play Beyond just the story
if you are focused mostly on narrative
however you can take solace in the fact
those missions are only open to you and
your selected party so you don't have to
worry about a random player joining for
the ride it's these live service
elements and some of the hints at
endgame content encounters that suggest
a long tail is being planned for Diablo
4 which should come as no surprise given
how long blizzard has actively supported
its predecessor yet in speaking with
Gamespot executive producer Rod Ferguson
seemed apologetic for how he felt
blizzard underserved the Diablo
community at the time vowing to change
that over the many years the developer
plans to support Diablo 4 with new
content including expansions seasonal
events and more
if this brief slice is meant to serve as
a teaser for the foundations of that
ambition then Diablo 4 seems on the
right track it's so far delivering on
its promise of giving players far more
agency than before in how they both play
and build their favorite characters
while also providing more ways to tackle
content and choose the activities that
interest them first that might not sound
overtly original but within the context
of the series over the last decade it's
a drastic and so far welcome departure
that I'm both curious and excited to
explore more of for our full Impressions
with our time Hands-On with Diablo 4 as
well as interviews with key members of
the development team head to
gamespot.com
foreign